[Music]  where are we  the meadows but where is that  i want to introduce you to our latest  recruit  some of you may remember her from a  previous occasion but i want you to  erase that from your mind  [Music]  it's not gonna be like it was before  [Music]  we're going to give you a new life  is it true you were taken away from us  when you were very young  yes  oh you're one of us now they're  perfectly refined military tools  when socialization is complete all we  have to do is flip a switch  and on the other side  so you make up their names the families  in the pretend lives yes i do  well i already have a name  you know none of this is real they're  training you to kill people  it's real to me  hannah you think you understand what's  happening here  maybe it's time you realize who your  family really are  useful force  [Music]  [Music]  you